how introverts can be successful so I've
got a great question for one of my
facebook fans Richard who wrote in to
say hi Evan I love your videos and the
fact that you give so much inspiration
and help for free Wow I appreciate that
a lot everyone I need advice from you
because you know what you are talking
about to be successful these days means
to do all kinds of social networking
because it isn't about the product so
much but people need to feel passion as
you have said and I agree but I'm sure
that you know that for an introvert it
isn't easy to be that outgoing and I'm
sure that there are lots of introverts
with passion for something out there who
want to be successful too so what would
you recommend to them to be successful
thank you so much appreciate your help
Evan Richard this is a fantastic
question and one that has deep personal
meaning to me as well because you may
not believe it watching the videos but
I'm actually an introvert and you may
get a better sense of that looking back
on my old videos if you look 3-4 years
back and look at the videos they're
they're not as outgoing and passionate
and expressive as I am now and I've had
to work on that not so much in terms of
being more extroverted but just tapping
into my passion more and that brings out
a more excited Evan you know I really
want to help entrepreneurs you ask a
question like that and I wanted to have
an impact on your life and I know a lot
of the videos that I make really helps
people and so that makes me excited and
passion and I'm just talking in front of
a video camera but it's being
broadcasted out I'm not the guy who goes
out and networks with people I hate
networking events I hate small talk I
don't hand out my business card to
everybody we have a business card
anymore you know I don't talk to the guy
next to me the airplane I don't check
people up on the bus I'm not I'm not
that extroverted guy if you're that
person too
you don't want to get down on yourself
and think oh there's no way I'm going to
be successful because there's so many
successful entrepreneurial introverts
you just you may not hear about them as
much because the experts when one's
making all the noise
right you don't have to be the Richard
Branson doing the publicity
stance and everybody loves the dude you
can be super introverted and still have
a lot of success how do you do it here
are my two rules for you
the first is follow your passion and
this applies if you're extrovert or
introvert right you got to do something
that you love and I know which would you
you already mentioned on your Facebook
comment but you got to love what you do
right you cannot be successful on a big
scale doing stuff that you hate right if
you are not passionate about what you're
doing day-in day-out you will not be
massively successful it's just not
possible you have to find things that
you love doing you could put your heart
into and be super excited and passionate
about like I am making these videos for
you guys and they're going to be better
right that's going to help you become
successful so you have to follow your
passion number two is build a team a
success in in business and in life is
not a solo affair you know you need
people around you to support what you're
doing if you're launching a company
there are skill sets that you need to
have a successful company and you may
have some of them as an introvert
whatever your background is and you need
support of other people to help you
round that out and that may be in terms
of partnerships you have people come on
who are your equity partners in the
business or you hire it out you know you
hire contractors or you hire employees
to join you in your team and do the
things that you're not good at because
again if you're you know if there's five
things that you need for your business
to be successful and you're really good
at two of them and hate the other three
the solution is the solution is not
rather I'm going to learn the other
three and suck at them and hate them
because I need that to be successful the
solution is to focus on the two you're
really good at and get other people to
do the other things right if you're
passionate about something and other
people are attracted that passion their
passion for the same thing but bring
different skill sets then you're going
to work really really really well
together so you know an example making
these videos christina edits all these
videos hi Christina and she believes in
entrepreneurs she believes and believe
she loves the mission that we're on and
she has way better video editing skills
than I do right if the videos relied on
me to edit
and add the music and add all the stuff
that Cristina adds to it first of all we
take way longer I couldn't do as many I
couldn't answer as many questions for
you and second of all I would I would
slowly hate it right like ah I just want
to get in front of the camera and
respond the people I don't want to have
to do all that post-production work but
Cristina is awesome at it and she makes
these stories pop a little more than
just then I would be able to do you
surround yourself with people who who
can support you and you want to build a
success team to take you where you want
to go the third thing is leverage your
strengths if you want to think what are
you really good all right what can you
be one of the best in the world at and
really focus on those things so for
example as I said I'm not the guy going
out making sales calls and cold calling
and going to trade shows and doing
networking events and that is one way to
drum up sales right and it works it's
work for a lot of people but it it won't
work for me because that's not my
personality I'm too introverted to go
out and do all that stuff and so I I've
leveraged my strengths and focus on
marketing instead of sales to help drive
business to me it's a lot easier at
least for me when people are calling and
are interested in what I'm doing and
want to work together then for me to
pick up the phone and cold call somebody
and say hey I'm Evan do you want to work
together and so I've created an engine
that creates an inflow of leads for me
and that is through making the videos
that's through my website that's through
my newsletters through my social media
stuff I'm putting out stuff and building
an audience and that attracts people to
me to want to work together with me on a
whole bunch of different projects so you
know if you're not that kind of sales
person II out meet meet and greet
getting everybody's face kind of guy
then you can focus more on the marketing
side and again pouring your passion into
it right you can express yourself you
have to make videos okay you don't have
to be super comfortable on camera you
don't to do interviews but find the
medium that works best for you maybe you
love time to think and to write and so
thoughtful blog post is what you come up
with or Twitter is your platform or
Facebook is your platform maybe you like
designing you know pictures are taking
taking your own pictures
Photography and matching them with
quotes or whatever it is right fine
whatever medium works best for you that
you can express your passion through and
just leverage the heck out of that one
make it awesome I want to feel your
passion coming through everything that
you create the the acid test for me in
creating something that goes to social
is what am i proud of this you know when
I post that tweet am i proud of what I
just created when I put that picture on
Facebook and my am i proud I feel like
yeah I created that I'm gifting this to
the world
and I think other people will be
inspired by it right so you have to have
that same feeling of I'm really proud of
what I'm creating what I'm doing and
pouring my heart into this message for
you to consume and that will lead you to
have success on social media whether
you're doing it in Twitter or Facebook
or YouTube videos where you're on camera
or making your you know music videos or
whatever you're going to do love with
your strengths and pour your heart into
it so remember follow your passion build
a team leverage your strengths believe
those are watching if you like this
video you can support me by clicking on
the link in the description leave a
comment below let me know what you think
your comments means so much to me I love
seeing them come in and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon